alors que les opérations de pompage ont
repris hier sur la partie arrière cette
fois de l'épave de l'erika permettant de
récupérer 870 tonnes de fioul
l'heure est au premier bilan pour les
stations touristiques de la façade
atlantique touchés par la marée noire de
décembre dernier sur l'île de
noirmoutier le bilan des 15 premiers
jours de juillet est plutôt rassurant
même si on enregistre une baisse de la
fréquentation sur place christophe de
vallon bras et alain bari grands ils
sont moins nombreux que d'habitude sur
les plages de noirmoutier mais ils sont
tout de même venus aujourd'hui lille a
totalement effacé les traces de l'erika
mais ici on savait que l'image des
boulettes de fioul sur le sable serait
beaucoup plus tenaces
on craignait même une saison
catastrophique en fait la première
quinzaine de juillet plutôt rassurantes
la baisse de fréquentation est certaine
mais elle n'est pas aussi importante
qu'on pouvait le craindre
ça tourne plus autour de moi 20% que
moins 30 moins 50 % comme on a pu le
craindre une certaine époque mais ces
premiers chiffres sont très variables la
principale baisse touche les locations
une clientèle souvent familial est donc
très attiré par la plage en termes
d'image de marque
on a relativement souffert de ce qui
s'est passé là on constate en termes de
demande qu'on a à peu près non écrit
moines d'habitude
de demandes de location simplement en
termes de réservations là on a nettement
un bon quart d'heure
- touché les campings de lille
enregistrent une baisse de fréquentation
d'environ 15%
mais la situation s'améliore avec la
météo les féeriques 1 devrait lui être
limité ce que nous pouvons enregistrer
comme baisse sensible de 10 voire 5%
actuellement
nora je pense pas d'incidence je vais
moins je l'espère sur l'ensemble de la
saison pour les restaurateurs en
revanche aucun problème certains avaient
même sous-estimer leurs besoins en
personnel les premiers jours de juillet
houde était excellent on a été un petit
peu aidé par mauvais temps qui vous a
amené beaucoup de passage sur l'île en
fait on a récupéré grande partie de la
course agents du monde
adam
la boule mais tous les chiffres de cette
première quinzaine ne sont que des
indices il faudra bien sûr attendre la
fin de la saison sur l'île pour mesurer
le véritable impact de la marée noire
ils sont moins nombreux que d'habitude
sur les plages de noirmoutier venu
aujourd'hui lille a totalement effacé
les traces de l'erika mais ici on savait
que l'image des boulettes de fioul sur
le sable serait beaucoup plus tenaces
on craignait même une saison
catastrophique en fait la première
quinzaine de juillet plutôt rassurantes
c'est important ça tourne plus autour
mais ces premiers chiffres sont très
variables la principale baisse touche
les locations une clientèle souvent
familial est donc très attiré par la
plage en termes d'image de marque
on a relativement souffert de ce qui
s'est passé là on constate en termes de
demande
on a à peu près moitié moins que
d'habitude de demandes de location
simplement en termes de réservations là
on a nettement moins touché les campings
de lille enregistrent une baisse de
fréquentation d'environ 15%
mais la situation s'améliore avec la
météo les féeries cas devrait lui être
limité
ce que nous pouvons enregistrer comme
baisse sensible de 10 voire 5%
actuellement
nora je pense pas d'un silence je vais
moins je l'espère sur l'ensemble de la
saison pour les restaurateurs en
revanche aucun problème certains avaient
même sous-estimer leurs besoins en
personnel les premiers jours de juillet
ont été excellents on a été un petit peu
aidés
vous aviez beaucoup de passage sur l'île
en fait on a récupéré grande partie de
la course un changement notre dame
mais tous les chiffres de cette première
quinzaine ne sont que des indices il
faudra bien sûr attendre la fin de la
saison sur l'île pour mesurer le
véritable impact de la marée noire